Gary lak's team slaps back at Jeff DT's
false claims he was blackmailed into
resigning over bribery tape and says
resigned Arizona Republican party chair
should apologize for his unethical
Behavior so ho whoa whoa we got to slow
down here Jeff dwit is the guy who was
caught on camera and we've called it
bribery of of Carrie Lake I actually
think it's blackmail I think blackmail
is a better term is there an amount of
money I don't think he's trying to bribe
her when they both
explicitly are bringing up that when
when she says they're going to have me
murdered krie Lake says that in the
recording and he's like well if it's
true about the report with the cartel is
operating in all 50 states that doesn't
sound like bribery that's like a guy
came in and said be a shame if one of
these cartels people got you why don't
you take a job and just don't bother the
people back East that sounds like
blackmail call it bribery whatever well
the latest news is that this guy
resigned he's claiming that the audio
has been altered in some way and car L's
team came to him and said more audio
will be released unless you resign now K
Lake's team is disputing this but I got
to tell you when you listen to the audio
my guy ain't nobody made you become a
scumbag who's going to go to Cary Lake
and offer her cash to drop out of
politics I was wondering is he getting a
cut is that why he was doing that I was
going to say he's a little fish who is
the big guy that's paying him to talk to
carry Lake and say hey we don't want you
to run in the senate race for next two
years you know lay down cuz there's no
way out of his own brain he said the
People Back East who's the people back
East that are funding this corruption
not just in the state of Arizona but
there's more people that are being
bribed or blackmailed into running
exactly who is they they were they
didn't say numbers Carrie was like what
a billion that's not no I'm not going to
do it I'm like I can't be bought did you
guys play this video last night any of
it portions of it it's 10 minutes long
and it is edited I mean the shocking
thing is you know she says what 1
million 2 million it's not worth it and
I'm thinking like I know cuz right the
number is probably around 10 10 million
I'm gone I'll be out the door no I'm
just kidding but uh uh the the question
is they don't bring up in the video who
who they is right they say they are
saying this they said it's powerful
people back East so I have to assume
it's it's deep State it's intelligence
assets it's it's leaders of industry
it's people uh likely in DC well even
Carrie brought this up in the video is
like it's because they're anti-trump and
they the People Back East they're going
to put their money where their mouth is
I definitely think it's the Deep State
because they're going to do anything to
get the people that are backing Trump
and I mean car lake is one of the
biggest people in the country who is
backing Trump and who has been
unapologetically on that train so I
think it all goes back to this upcoming
election not even her Senate race the
term deep state in this context I mean
when I think of the deep state I'm
specific in thinking about like
bureaucracy so I'm thinking of actual
government agencies so your your whether
whether it be the EPA or it be uh you
know DEA or whatever it is a justice
department whatever I'm thinking of some
kind of government
agency I don't know where they're going
to come up with money to bribe her out
of an actual government agency I think
that it's more likely that it would be
like someone that sends money to S to PX
like a a wealthy investor something like
that than than actually you know an act
ual person in the government So when you
say de deep State I think of actual Bure
bureaucracy that's actually in the
government as opposed to which of these
highlevel donors also murder
people that's why deep State fits
better powerful uh interests uh special
interests massive coffers and the means
and will to assassinate well she it the
assassination when they were like I
don't think they're going to do that and
the and the guy what's his name Adams
McAdams the GU Jeff DT Jeff dwit was
like yeah I don't think they're going to
do that they
implying assassinate car Lake they he
said they would no they in the very
beginning they talked about it and then
there was a cartel thing but then about
6 minutes in they talked about the
People Back East doing it and they were
both like no I don't think they would do
that end more money guys at the end of
the video he says if paraphrasing if I
go public my car I will put my key in my
car yeah yeah he did say that she says
they're going to have me murdered and he
said well if it's true about the cartel
operating all 50 states you know then at
the end she says go public go no no no
no no no then I turn my key in my car
and well if he said cartel talking about
is he talking about drug cartels or was
was he using the the phrase more
Ambiguously talking about the drug
cartel yeah they said that the very
beginning was out of context you missed
the what they were talking about but
they said the cartel is operating in all
50 states or something like that and I
it just assumes that he's talking about
the Mexican drug cartel with with this
video being released like I'm at the
point now where anybody can come to me
with any conspiracy conspiracy theory
and I'm going be like well I believe you
over the government or the Press like
all the stuff they kept saying was a lie
remember when Epstein was a conspiracy
theory yeah and then Amy robach over at
ABC has that video leaked where she's
like I had it I had it Mike cernovich
files this paperwork with Mark randazza
Miami I think it's what the Miami Herold
was that or who was it was Miami Harold
who got involved or was it times I'm not
sure might have been the her I'm it sure
you want a fact check but more
journalists get involved we get these
documents released and then this forces
the hand for them to go after Epstein
and all of a sudden it wasn't a
conspiracy the anymore Alex Jones was
not was not crazy it was just well of
course then Epstein dies while in jail
with the cameras failing and the guards
falling asleep I think it was Julie K
brown with uh with the Miami Herold yeah
the heral okay that that's what i' I've
come to see is like all this dirty dark
potential is like I used to just kind of
wash it out and be like no no no that's
video game stuff that's movie villain
stuff that's not real stuff and now like
oh if it can be done there's a
likelihood that it is being done bro I
used to I used to think very much the
same way that life is much more boring
than people realize and I still think
that's true to a degree but holy crap
Carrie Lake published audio of a guy
saying people back East want to pay you
money to drop out of the race yeah oh
not to drop out just to pause her
campaign pause for well yeah that's a
drop out pause for a couple
years car will explode if he goes public
is there anyone else that's that's
running against her or is running
against her that's that's on the
conservative
side know she have someone that she's
because I imagine if they want her to
drop out they would want her to drop out
or to pause her campaign because they
would they have someone that they would
prefer to be in the
position if it were if it were a
conservative or if it were someone I
think at this point all the Republicans
should drop out of the primary a
2024 yeah it's the Republican primary
for US Senate so you've got Christopher
Bersa unofficially withdrew Leonard fure
Carrie Lake Mark Lamb Connie Moreno
Elizabeth Ray Robert Walker Allen White
Brian Wright I think they should all
drop out I like Mark Lamb you what I
like Mark Lamb I think they should all
drop out all of them but carrye yep yeah
Carrie is massively popular she's
nationally popular and the concern now
is look I I'll put it this way I don't
live in Arizona take it with a grain of
salt you don't got to take my advice any
one of these people I'm not going to get
mad at them if they don't drop out but
my view is I don't trust anyone who
stays
in the the the chair of the Republican
party you know he's in communication
with these people who are running did he
go to any of these other candidates and
offer them a bribe to drop out
definitely not I would I would assume no
it's Carrie Lake she's Maga she's Trump
they want Trump to lose and you know
that pause does not mean pause she drops
out for two years she's gone oh yeah and
then they'd expose that they bribed her
after the fact and then she' tarnish her
name with that absolutely they'd publish
the bribe and say look Carri Lake took
money to drop out she's been corrupt the
whole time now I look at these other
people who are running and I'm like
which one of them is in cahoots with
with dwit because DT's going to carry
leg saying drop out the inverse is
happening he's going to one of these
guys and being like how much can we give
you that does suck that these people
would even be remotely implicated cuz a
lot of these people are probably just
honestly trying to trying to run and
then they got all this malfant at the
top yep and then they're part of this
dirty system but hey that's politics
that's politics man and we're in the
United States which is apparently the
least worst but it's probably not the
least worst because the power that you
can gain if you get control of that
system it's all back scratching I
scratch your back you scratch mine
that's what even Carrie was talking
about like he she's the only one that
will say no because there are too many
politicians whether it's federal
government or state governments that are
being paid off actively by whether it's
the GOP by democrats by Deep State there
are too many people corrupt people in
our government systems and they're being
paid on they're just being paid by super
packs or by by donors to get in there
which is technically a legal thing so
you wouldn't even call them being paid
off but it's like then they be holding
to the where they their money oh it's
just so have you guys uh bought any
emergency
food dude I mean come on listen we knew
2024 was going to be wild it's 2023
we're like it's going to get crazy it's
the first month in and there are armed
National Guards
declare and the governor of Texas
declaring Supremacy over the border with
the federal government trying to open
the border and we have again still the
first month in Carrie Lake releasing
audio of an attempt to bribe her n
blackmail her into dropping out with the
fear of death on the line from a guy who
fears they will kill him if this if this
information goes public a wow I didn't
know it was going to kick off this quick
I was like maybe by the time
springtime's coming around things are
getting warmer we're going to get crazy
riots and there's going to be weird
stories about you know ptes or
something man yo March 5th is going to
be a crazy day it it was Trump getting
in and being like everyone there's a
deep State look under the covers this is
what it looks like and uh everyone lost
their and but then it's having
Biden in office which is so bad like
it's not that I hate the guy it's that
he's mentally incompetent that he's aged
so rapidly and in the last four years
and like the vacancy is is why a lot of
this junk is is matters so I mean Obama
wouldn't be so stupidly challenging
Texas's Authority in Texas like that's
that's a mani do you think Biden's
really up to it though cuz I think
there's other people behind the scenes
that are they're the ones that are
telling hey Abbott you guys were going
to come and sees your National Guard and
we're going to open up the border and
you guys are then going to have to pay
for the buses and the flights I mean I'm
in Sky Harbor just in Phoenix every
single week and I see dozens if not
hundreds of illegal immigrants getting
on airplanes every single day I talk to
the the uh TSA agents all the time and
it's not stopping whether it's Texas or
Arizona I'll tell you what scares me the
most it's not actually the Border it's
not uh Biden and his fumbling bumbling
speech what scares me the most is that
when Biden says Tre sh of pressure The
Crowd Goes yay man Luke posted this
Lukowski Biden goes because when you
mess with
Y you got you got can't and The Crowd
Goes screaming cheering I'm like
the emperor has no clothes book was
written about quite literally said no
words and the crowd was cheering an
uproar remember this I'm listen this is
a crowd where someone I mean look people
talk about the fervor of Nazis and how
they screamed and cheered for Hitler
Hitler was speaking to them yeah at
least he was saying words what he was
saying he was saying things they were
terrible but they're terrible things but
the thing is the opposition could
discern their plans
Joe Biden stands up and
goes and then hands everybody a club and
they go and then they start marching
around and you're like what are they
doing everyone in the back looks like a
deranged feminist know Millennial white
woman who's just so unhappy with their
lives I I I I have to assume it's all
like AI generated video it's this
there's a book called The Emperor wears
no clothes where and I have never read
the book but I know the premise is that
the emperor they' come out and I know if
it's China or whatever they'd March
around and the emperor would be naked
but they'd be like look at the beautiful
outfit that the emperor has on is it is
it beautiful everyone look the emperor
is wearing a beautiful outfit isn't it
beautiful and everyone would be like yes
yes beautiful outfit and then eventually
one kid little kid was like Emperor's
not wearing any clothes and everyone's
like and it's this moment of cognitive
dissonance where like youthful innocence
overrides this corrupt I don't know what
you would call it stupidity or can you
show your parents the video of him the
recent one where he goes you and the
crowd starts cheering yeah I got to find
it and then but don't show them any
commentary on it just play the video for
them ask them what they think and then
whatever they end up saying ask them
again why do you think the crowd is
cheering despite not knowing what Biden
said yeah they're cheering for the
regime that's the terrifying part
they're they're cheer that that shows
you Biden could literally call for the
extermination of a group of people and
they would cheer for it they got an
interesting perspective some of these
older people because they saw Biden in
the 80s 90s 2000 7s man yeah they they
so they they still see like his youth in
him when they look at him I just see
what I see which is right
straightforward I mean I I got
introduced to the guy 2008 thought he
was a scumbag I don't know why Obama
picked him probably was he was chosen
for Obama because they needed some dark
money in there old man they need my old
man when I look at him now I look at
like a vacant pale thin wispy ancient
and it's it's not in a good way like I I
I see this dilapidated uh nonsense but I
think a lot of people are still they
still see that Joe from 2006 that old
smile and a wink going to write that
crime Bill and plagiarize my
presidential campaign y like I don't
know how that got swept under the rug
that he's a plagiarist too it's the
worst thing Dr out 1988 he dropped out
of the presidential campaign cuz he got
caught plagiarizing his numerous
times let me just stress this again for
you guys right now though the Border
stuff is scary the the People Back East
man that's a quote we got to keep the
People Back East that's a scary quote
who are they yeah the fact that large
crowds will cheer for Biden with Biden
not saying words is much more terrifying
because this means these people could be
handed weapons and they'll just scream
and cheer for anything Biden could say
something abhorent and they would scream
and cheer for it at least when Donald
Trump says lock her up people chant back
lock her up with Joe Biden and they're
like yay I did get a horrible vision of
the president ordering people to turn on
American citizens like whoever an
outgroup of some sort whether you call
it the the the Nazis the the magga
Republicans the black people the white
people you pick a group
and then but in my mind I visualized
people cheering it on being like
literally happening that's not to
Germany like that's happening now it's
been happening for like a year longer it
literally happened when Hillary Clinton
said uh the basket of deplorables people
cheered for that but but worse than that
they've been calling Trump supporters
maggots yeah for years now and Joe Biden
says his his first campaign commercial
was they are your enemy and Must Be
Stopped I see the cheering like of for
the rhetoric but I was visualizing like
a guy on the street getting clubbed and
other people getting on the news and
people being like yeah get and like
don't let the country come to that don't
become that guy bro that's like that's
like TV in 2020 I was seeing all that
happening already I feel I feel it's
it's been going on all the stuff that
you're you're you're worried about
possibly happening in the future has
happened in the past happened in 2020
people were getting beats it happened in
Nazi Germany we should take a message we
should take a Learning
lesson the leader goes those are your
enemies exact same thing since like
2015 when Milo was getting punched in
the face that like you don't you can't
sit there and just say oh punch a Nazi
it's okay we need to calm these things
down all of that was the start of what
we're seeing now that was almost 10
years ago and then you have Chris rayun
who made a song punch a Nazi which was a
satirical version of Paparazzi by Lady
Gaga pointing out how these people are
going around saying that you that
encourage people to engage in violence
against anyone they disagree with and
the threats of of violence were so
extreme Chris Reagan took the video down
a couple years later and then totally
just disappeared off the face of the
earth I I think he still does videos of
some sort but man did he runs he run he
ran in panic he got rid of it yeah but
he got rid of it that's crazy this is
not something that's coming in the
future this is not like the government
being against a group of of Americans
the IRS has all was used to Target
Americans in like 2012 yeah 12 years ago
this is not someday this is coming this
is happening right now the I know that
it's Donald Trump but like they're
they're
fabricating and and doing everything
they can to circumvent due process to
just slap this guy with punishments I I
feel like there is some scapegoating
happening from the top rhetorically but
people are strong mentally to not fall
for it I just want to encourage people
to continue to not fall for it and don't
scapegoat other groups of people they
have not
they have not not fallen for it they
have fallen hookline and sinker for it I
know people that have not fallen for it
that I would have thought have there are
some people that have not of course but
I think that the the reason that we talk
about things like people kind of realize
that things are bad when they saw like
what their kids were seeing in schools
during covid or when they saw the way
that the government uh was behaving
during Co all of that stuff had been
there were people warning about that
stuff for at least a decade prior
at least 10 years before all of that
stuff happened there were people saying
hey this is happening this is happening
some people were saying it 20 years
earlier like Alex Jones as as much as
people hate to admit it like Alex Jones
was was predicting some of the some of
the crazy remember he predicted 911 yeah
you know he was 20 years ago in July of
2001 Alex Jones there's like a famous
recording of Jones you can watch it
where he's like they're going to be
targeting the World Trade Centers and
other places with Terror attacks and and
then he's and he talks for a little bit
then he mentions Obama I'm sorry Obama
AMA Bin Laden will be the main scapegoat
they've used him before blah blah blah
and it's just like you can watch his
videos that was like in May of 2001 he
was talking about it five or six months
before stuff is not coming stuff is here
just that Americans have not noticed
because it is not they have not targeted
enough Americans that to the point where
the the left leaning kind of bad
liberals Democrats that should be more
liberal than they are um until those
people start start seeing it until they
start their friends start paying for it
until the laptop class starts paying for
it there will be no changes that's why
they moving these these illegal
immigrants to the cities is is crude as
it is I think is the most effective eye
opening because it forces you to look at
it it forces you to be be holding to it
it's like it's like what Phil is saying
about the laptop class it's like if if
your daily life is so comfortable using
one of these guys and you have dopamine
feed from you know your TV Etc whatever
you're watching on TV and you're
comfortable like always mentions like
people that are in like in a comfortable
situation don't Revolt because they're
just like their everyday life is so is
is so cushy there's no reason there's
like well what's what's so bad about
this happening it doesn't affect me so
like it you're like you said it's crude
but it's the only way to make people
experience it otherwise they're not
going to it's never going to be a thing
in their life ever that is Gen Z in a
nutshell though because every single gen
Zer on a college campus first of all
they go to an indoctrination camp
they're learning everything that the
establishment wants them to learn and
then they go on their phones for the
rest of the day and they're just sucked
in and Liv living this mundane life
doing absolutely nothing and they're
just rotting like literally Jen's brains
are rotting especially in college
campuses and nothing is going to solve
it until we continue to press and make
people wake up I mean the whole Biden
Gaff thing that happened was at his
restore row rally where you see just
dozens of these Millennial jenzy women
that are chanting for pro-choice and you
know therefore legal genocide of you
know babies being aborted in our country
which is absurd but that those are the
kind of issues that these women are
grasping on to and supporting Biden for
and same thing with the technology I
think they're Pro transhumanism you know
gen Z is trending in the direction of
the more crazy the better I I mean I
talk to kids all the time that have read
The Communist Manifesto and they endorse
Carl Marx and they love socialism like
on college campuses I mean I've had
fascist yell fascist in my face and it's
oh yeah it happens on every single
campus across the country and I think
it's only getting worse until we
continue I mean I know turning points
you know we're actually out there
talking to kids but we're going to need
more of it because these kids need to
reverse the brainwashing that they've
been going through for years yeah the
it's like you want to wake people up to
horror without putting them through
horror the horror of like scapegoating
your government scapegoating a class of
person that that we have it on camera
Hitler doing that to the Jews and the
gypsies but particularly the Jews so we
have a evidence like don't ever do that
ever again but how do you how do you get
people to realize that Maga Republican
thing is a is a scapegoat attempt to get
him to wake up to like don't ever do
that again how do you make him do it
again you just you just say like oh well
you blame the people for doing exactly
what you're doing here here here here's
here's the challenge I
see there are very powerful people who
are involved with abstein level stuff
and it's periphery who don't want to be
exposed and I think it's probably bigger
than people realize so I think it was
Bill Maher who was doing his Club random
is that the name of his show yeah and he
said Jimmy Kimmel is the last person who
would be on
on this list it's a it's laughable he's
a regular guy oh Jimmy Kim's a nice guy
why was Bill Mah
lying why why would Bill Mah lie was
Bill Maher on the list is Bill Mah on
the related to this is he involved in
this stuff big Hollywood guy Bill Mah
has been single for a long time uh Jimmy
Kimmel is Friends W with Epstein's
personal chef and they've reportedly
been in business together in varing
capacities so why would Jimmy Kimmel's
name appear on the list or in in lists
related to those in in the in the circle
of Epstein because he In Cahoots with
Epstein's Chef that's one degree of
separation we're talking about Kevin
Bacon we're talking about a like my
friend literally works for the guy we
hang out all the time he's got a
restaurant I I I go to when you get
people like Bill Maher who are trying to
cover up and trying to downplay the
severity of what's going on it makes me
it makes me feel like the the sphere of
corruption it related to uh intelligence
assets EP Etc the Deep state is much
wider than people realize and if it's
not the case that Bill Maher has
something to hide he's so stupid he is
pushing people in the wrong direction
causing damage and so what I see from
this is how do we convince the people
the Maga Republican thing is a big lie
it's tough because the Maga Republican
thing this is the principal faction
calling out those who are connected to
Epstein in child trafficking and Jimmy
Kimmel is in that sphere of influence
but he's got powerful allies assets
resources and money that will use the
the media to lie to people because he
does not want to be involved he doesn't
not he does not want to like he does not
want people coming out being like did
you know that he was he was really good
friends with Epstein cheff that's bad
for him so you get powerful interest
interests being like you know what ends
up happening is someone says yeah if I
talk bad about him I bring this up I
can't go on his show and that's that
that is a it is it is not just that
people are on the Epstein list it's that
there may be a guy who knows who is on
the list and thinks yeah but if I call
him out he won't buy my product anymore
that sphere of influence is massive
absolutely massive they're going to do
everything in their power to keep that
covered up in every capacity I maybe we
can try and make some some Nuance on the
Epstein stuff because like most people
that were connected with Epstein had no
they didn't have sex with underage women
I would imagine like Frank Reynolds in
It's Always Sunny he was just there for
the snorkeling yeah exactly he know Tak
the SES people a lot of people prop just
did business with EP cuz he was a big
businessman and loved to make
connections but never got to the level
of going on the plane with them or they
knew somebody that knew Epstein and like
if they're afraid of acknowledging the
thing then they're going to be hiding
the people as well that did the nasty so
we we we should maybe go ease off on
some of the people that were connected
to it uh to try and find the darkest
well shout out to the It's Always Sunny
team because their latest season Frank
Reynolds is like I went to the island
and they're like what and he's like I
didn't know anything about it I was
there for the snorkeling but because
it's absurd like how could you have gone
there and not known what was going on
the Island's not that big I bet it was
like some people were having dinner wild
parties while was like six of the dudes
went into back rooms and those are the
guys they got on that that clip bro the
girls were on the plane there's no way
if anybody was on a plane getting to the
island they didn't know about the child
trafficking no way if if you know you
just had a one single meeting behind
closed doors with abstein or you saw him
at a party crossan shook hands that's
one thing like photograph with him but
if you were on the plane I don't think
there was there's no doubt in my mind
that they knew about this thing is if I
met Epstein and I went to a restaurant
and I sat down and it was Epstein and
some girl that looked like 16 and he's
like she's a model I wouldn't question
it thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net